I want my
fist to almost be
like a Mason chain
okay in this drill I'm not trying to
drive anything we might I even leave my
fist loose do you see it
okay and I'm going to create some torque
in my
body okay but really I want to
settle what's what I'm really working on
to rotate the
[Music]
heel and then to plant again I had to
settle okay my fist is
loose don't try to kill
anything okay loose loose loose not like
this this something
different loose loose loose all I'm
really trying to do is this merge with
gravity okay on the back heel is where I
want you to put your focus just make
sure you keep your elbow tight so you
don't do weird things on your wrist but
Loose
fist okay here we
go so uh we'll do that
this in this part now I my fist comes
with just that mace energy mace energy
wow okay but now what I'm going to do is
after it makes contact with that mace
energy you're going to feel the Yang
aspect of the target okay and that's
what I'm going to project out okay
um so you have to be ready for that it's
very very subtle so I do the same
drop same
looseness okay let's
try so now I'm in that
last part where I settled okay and
that's the one I'm going to use so I'm
here and I do this this time no rotation
boom
settle
settle just as loose my high is just as
loose settle okay let's try
it so he his y the Y aspect of the
target is resistance okay it's young
energy so and that's what I'm using to
project just like if he's pushing into
me that's what I used to project so when
I hit the target boom it's the same
thing that I used to project you guys
understand that it's just a aot foster
okay so now I I'm didn't I'm not going
to use my hips I'm not even going to use
from here to here I'm just here I just
do the real
boom
Target feel the feel the Y rebound on
the back foot
boom okay let's try now I'm going to
collapse to the
Elbow but everything's the
same of course that would be like move
that thing out of the way right so I I
could be here and then I drop it onto
the solar plexus okay so that's all the
movement but this is where I'm at I I'll
hit and I'll
ground okay let's try so in in all this
stuff we're trying to settle so here
torque to settle here settle okay here
settling inside settling inside okay
well same thing now I'm moving I don't
want to hit you with my foot in the
air it's when my foot settles boom boom
is when I hit
okay don't hit up I'm not trying to hit
up oh I'll exaggerate it now my weight
came up my energy goes down that's when
it hits that's where the rebound
is hitting right when your foot hits is
where is where you're going to find the
rebound if your foot's not up in the air
because I'm I'm leaving I'm changing my
grounding Vector okay when I hit here I
don't want to be on the back leg I want
to be on the front the front leg the
front leg push the front leg is what's
doing the
grounding you see not not my back leg so
think about it I'm over here
it's not going to work it's on the front
leg okay so it goes with when you
hit when you hit ground boom you kind of
exaggerate it at first
boom boom okay try it again okay so uh
it's not in the movement going forward
it's not in the hip rotation it's it's
not even in the foot going down okay
it's in the come away from there from
the Yang aspect going down okay it has
nothing to do with the momentum range
either so we're going to go up
now
okay if you're just doing this
externally you'll lose power and you
come up okay it's inside your
body and he'll go out so I'm going up
okay no
movement up boom
okay and so
again last time move move move the back
come here okay last time I went boom
down this one I'm going up so I can hit
up do you feel it go up you see you
could to have his head down and you'll
come up and you'll hit okay but either
way he's not going to be standing there
so as I'm going
down
base going up base two okay so when you
hit he's not going to be standing there
and that's what you have to have okay
try it again